I was pretending that there was a
half-life we should ask if anyone seen a
bear or a titter or a very small donkey
darling these creatures listen I will
fool dr. Cunningham on Monday I think
with the right amount of rest
[Music]
piglet my plan worked
I don't know how I do it you must be
Christopher Robin's wife how do you do
my bum words can't just keep saying
hello to people people can't see moving
and talking but why because because
you're different and people don't like
things that are different so I shouldn't
be me no no you know it's rose be
yourself no this is very confusing it
may be the hunger it's just evening oh
that's right never mind about that for
now just try and be less a less
exhibiting - you look stupid
flop sag Lulu yes I know I've got it how
about playing nap time I love play well
let's see it like this what to do what
to do what to do what to do indeed
Pooh Christopher Robin no no no no no
you can't be here
this can't be happening stress it's not
stress forest it's bull lost it
evan warned me I like to be warned wand
and cozy I've cracked
totally correct I don't see any cracks a
few wrinkles
maybe oh I do like a party mom baby what
should happen if you forget about me
silly old fair oh never forget about you
pay a promise even when I'm a hundred we
should be working this weekend Robin but
I promised my wife and daughter I'd take
them away this weekend all hands on deck
you won't be coming to the cottage you
can't be helped your life is happening
now right in front of you what to do
what to do what to do what to do indeed
poor Christopher Robin hello the tree I
remember was in the countryside not here
in London but Sir opening I suppose it's
where it needs to be that's a silly
explanation watch thank you who why are
you here oh yes I need your help
I've lost all of my friends let's get to
the bottom of this
look up here I come it would appear that
I am stuck have you do stateand honey I
have not just eating dirty I wonder
which way I always get to where I'm
going by walking away from where I have
been don't you that's the way I go I
turn
hello you're Christopher Robin it's you
later
let's gonna see if we can find think yes
I've already stayed far too long hello
everyone so nice to see you all again
watch thank you silly old bear I was
wrong about work I was wrong about
everything and I've got to get back to
my family
farewell Christopher Robin I would have
liked it to go on for a while longer
perhaps it's our turn to save
Christopher
[Music]
you must bring Matalin wait he all the
bear of my father's forums yes do you
know where he is I did I thought oh
strip us tourism
[Music]
[Applause]
piglet if anyone wants to clap now is
the time to do it I don't remember being
cheery people say nothing is impossible
but I do nothing every day
no kapu that's not
so we're both in Disney's Christopher
Robin and I thought everyone at home
might like to hear what it was like
making the movie that sounds quite nice
[Music]
hello everyone Christopher Robert first
question are you anything like your
character like who like me what was the
question again I was thinking about
lunch how would you describe your acting
style well I usually just agree with
everyone on set I'm too afraid to say no
I sometimes find it difficult to hone in
on a character's motivation
what's your secret you gotta think like
a Tigger act like a Tigger and it helps
to be a digger right but well what if
I'm not playing today
oh the predicament you're how do you
separate the Eeyore and scream from the
Eeyore behind the camera he's a bit
chewier than me winning absolutely he's
all laughs living on Oh
before we keep going you wouldn't happen
to have any honey would you well I'm
sure we could find some
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm sorry I got held up at work
you'll be working this weekend well it
can't be helped
father I never see your life is
happening now right in front of you
I am sorry Madeline
[Music]
what to do what to do what to do what to
do and become
Oh Christopher Robin no no no no no no
this can't be happening
stress but it's not stress let's pool
pool how are you here oh well I went
through the door through which
Christopher Robin is known to appear and
now I'm here the tree I remember was
behind the causes in the countryside not
here in London I suppose it's where it
needs to be that's a silly explanation
why thank you
I've lost all of my friends want you to
find them
well there are you on an expedition sir
Oh bother
hmm do you think he's all right
come here come in here look can't just
keep saying hello to people you can't
see moving and talking but why because
you're different so I shouldn't be me no
no yourself no this is very confusing
just try and be a less a less exuberant
you look Stuber and flop sag play nap
time I love play well let's see it like
this well done boom do you think it
might be able to amuse yourself for a
while and of course around about the
pressing block to do house clouds tree
go for what are you doing oh I'm playing
again
it's called say what you see look could
you say what you see a little more
quietly
[Music]
house grass I'm sorry the snack
compartment
it's rather full that's his nap time
[Music]
Christopher Robin good bad exactly
please giant and he smells a little
funny
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
just an average Wednesday morning not
who I used to be and lost you need to
remember who you are
Kristopher always comes to save us no
it's our turn to save him
let's bow
it's always a sunny day
when Christopher Robin comes to play
silly old better Disney's Christopher
Robin was called saying what you'll see
in faster your disgrace and of shame
humiliation well that's one way to play
it in theatres on his third rated PG get
tickets now hello Christopher Robin when
a the book speaks a lot of truth
they've got a great philosophy on life
people say nothing is impossible but I
do nothing every day
no poos that's not never mind
Christopher Robin his focus shouldn't be
on work and work and work it should
actually be on things that are important
to him the child anymore and the
adulthood responsibilities well it
doesn't sound like fun
well I think all the other characters
help him to realize he's living his life
in the wrong direction
doing nothing often leads to the very
basis to something who represents a
living in the moment and appreciating
that life has happened to you not
somewhere else but here
I always get to where I'm going by
walking away from where I
it's about something that we could all
use a bit of at the moment slowing
things down and realizing what's
important in our lives who is the great
philosopher you know
[Music]
was called an emergency meeting this
weekend I promised my wife and daughter
I'd take them away this weekend sir
we need to cut 28 assembly you were
promised these people good jobs and I
thought you'd do anything for this
company
have a good time
[Music]
[Music]
what to do what to do what to do
what to do in big
[Music]
who Christopher Robin I don't see any
cracks a few wrinkles maybe what to do
what to do what to do indeed who
Christopher Robin everybody knows Winnie
the Pooh whether you know him from a
melons books or from Disney's cartoons
he's really alive as a character and
people's imaginations however did you
recognize me
who ever changed a bit yes the
characters that's my generation my
parents generation and now this
generation or growing up with your the
Baron my father's drawings Wendy the
pool became a dear friend of mine when
Walt gave us the assignment to write
songs for the first Winnie the Pooh
short film and here's so many years
later it is very special to be back in
the Hundred Acre Wood well I didn't
expect to be here today does they're
doing a great job of bringing some of
their archive characters to life and as
exciting to be involved in Christopher
Robin hello everyone when a thought
comes back to him and in a difficult
time in his life Christopher Robin
always comes to save us no it's our turn
to save him he speaks a lot of truth
food it would appear that I am stuck
have you just eaten honey the whole new
generation is being introduced to this
beloved character is something very
exciting hello this is a charming story
of a man finding his home again and
finding that in a child
absolutely bare it really is a lovely
funny and adventure will come out the
better for it have you seen it I think
come on Oh
[Music]